hey guys this is des the founder take
care and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of agents of shield
episode 3 the asset um so yeah this is
like kind of like a controversial show i
didn't know this Marvel show's gonna be
so controversial if you say anything
negative about there's a lot of people
are gonna retaliate after that you can't
talk bad about this show without people
be like give it a chance it just started
on then on the opposite end if you say
you like it or you love it the people
who hate their like what are you talking
about this this show is real good
especially breaking bad just a new pro
life it was not close to breaking bad
like it's not even supposed to be and
it's not even the same right like
wheelhouse now I think a lot of us know
we've been talking with us to think he
was just a lot of us think had our
expectations set for a certain thing to
show we don't think any of us were
expecting this to be breaking better not
expect to be some drama or some serious
heavy show it's fun it's just we got the
ban searches it's it's fun silly it has
problems yes yes our problems and it's
definitely you know I don't like this
kind of story line of the week type of
stuff that yeah we've had so far but I
mean that's exhaust weena shall I me
right that's what it does he he does
these episodic type of stories right and
then he gets into the big main narrative
but he waits all the way to like season
two I mean I know he's not like show
running it right now but I know that he
does have input especially because not
only is a producer and he's supposed to
be overseeing the Marvel stuff but he's
you know his it's his brother and his
sister-in-law right are the show running
the show no he definitely has some sort
of influence over it i miss fun i make
us going in this episode I mean yeah it
is kind of the mystery of the we kind of
know which is fine i mean x-files did
that a lot of shows do is nothing wrong
with even you know fringe that we both
like things did that from time to time
but i hope they do eventually like
fringe you know build up to an overall
get that story going because this is the
perfect show whether it's on ABC hpo no
matter what is the perfect show to have
a nice big arc you know big story to
tell this is the perfect should i do it
but right now we're just kind of getting
the story the week right now yeah maybe
part of it is they're worried about
causing too many ripples
into the Marvel Cinematic Universe that
they're worried that like they're gonna
do something you can't make that's the
problem you can't make it too big all
right because we brought it they brought
an extremist in the first episode you
know from iron man 3 you have to wonder
if they're gonna bring in something from
for they are but as long as you can't do
something like an alien invasion let you
know is that big now yeah vendors are
adding you can't do something that's
gonna be like the end of the world
because that's for the like if the
shield shield um like let's say saves
the day and say my world then what's the
point of the the superheroes don't watch
me the small story yes a lot why is
there iron man why is there Thor why is
there Hulk if if shield themselves of
regular people or you know which is a
concern about the show if you wonder if
it that if the the marvel cinematic
universe is limiting that's what the
show can actually do that's what worries
me okay I'm not trying to go too fast
you're passed judgment as it is just
episode 3 we're still building up but
it's like is this show going to be
limited because of the Cinematic
Universe just how big that is like can
it really how much can it develop
without interfering with the movies I
think it's probably one of the problems
they're dealing with is because they're
trying to get you know bigger store
online but bigger consequences at the
same time they can't really yeah and
budget-wise and also with the the
problems of integrating into the Marvel
we know we've seen the previews we know
and thor the dark world at some alien
elf guys gonna come and attack earth
though you seen the trailers know it's
gonna happen so you can't have that and
then be like Marvel Age of she'll be
doing something else saving the world
it's like a weight Thursday when the
world over here is I can't yeah it's
just so I say go we can go small that's
a small go personal stone covert op
stuff yeah that's really that's fun do
you know relationship built a character
built stuff you know don't worry about
you know trying to like make it as as
big as the movies are and you know
spectacles right it can't be that and
that's what worries me a little about
the show is the character is right now
we're still learning about their little
flat yeah and i noticed a joss whedon so
but you know you know firefly is a great
example of how those are great
characters in the very beginning they
were good care
is really interesting you want to know
more about him right now these
characters need a little more character
Billy not drama not sad dark stuff but
just like even if it's funny this some
more character yeah they need more
development it is more on the silly side
you know light-hearted side I think I
think the problem with Firefly those its
kind of the oddball elestra joss whedon
show yeah it's the only one that likes
started right out of the gate break
uh-uh hitting its full stride where we r
you know Buffy and Angel dog house they
all took like a season or two just to
get things going and I think because of
agents of shield because it's tied to
the Marvel Universe they have the luxury
of being able to use that name to drag
on yo viewers will keep coming to
watching I bet towards the end of the
season is when we're gonna see a bigger
story line or merge but yeah I wanted
Yeah right wait would you think about
this story line with this the
gravitonium and I love made-up
scientific names gravitonium yeah um
that's good i mean you know we get to
see the sky you know the key the
computer hacker do her thing and you
know whatever her character supposed to
be able what's up yeah I mean yeah I
like i said i don't buy her as and hat
as a hacker and then now we learn more
about her and i still dont buyers right
now we find out she said she was an
orphan and she went from foster home to
foster home and was sent back and you
know like she's has a past yeah yeah
yeah I just I just don't buy that from
her curator I mean yeah but it was
always good i mean i'm glad to see that
what's her surname eena meena mean I was
gonna step up which learned in the
episode she's gonna issuance be full
combat yeah she's probably at from me
she's the coolest character on the show
I like her so I'm glad she's gonna be
having more role but I mean the whole
infiltrating and I don't know I mean
we'll see I mean again I hope these
stories that were right about payoff I
mean I don't hate him it's just I just
don't know what how about I mean yeah I
can't take care about it yet no no a
little underground computer hacking
thing I'm like I don't know if I you
know we'll see yeah yeah it's
it's much like with with Buffy and Angel
and and fringe in the beginning Buffy in
the being angel in the beginning where
it's like okay what storyline do we have
just for this episode right I like what
either monster or freak or villain or we
can attack all this and I'm hoping you
know you guys seen the episode so at the
end you know you see the hand come out
of yeah is that gonna come back in a
future better yeah and is it gonna be is
that gonna be like a main villain to
learn that's what they they're lacking
they're lacking a main villain they're
lacking some sort of you know either
organization there's no setup but you
said like you have only shows how a lot
of great new shows this fall you have
Sleepy Hollow obviously the horsemen you
know you have this thing this thing
that's comes that's big story you have
the blacklist you know you have this
plan it's blacklist of you know names
and things as always there's something
pulling these people to you know to
accomplish i'm playing fringe you know
immediately the first episode had a
mystery they had to uncover but like
with marlena shield i think they really
do need to find something that we're
working towards like what do we do in
besides flying around doing mission to
Mission I mean that's what they want to
do I'm entertained I like the show I'm
entertained by that on a weekly basis
but hopefully they'll have a bigger
story coming up in the few yeah also you
even within the show it's like not
exactly consisting so there be lines
that are funny right and then there be
lines that are cheesy yeah I'm like you
know let's get to the balancer more
funny and maybe get some more drama you
know not like a melodrama but drama yeah
i know i keep go back to fire five
nothing firefly had the best example of
comedy cuz it's funny thing for those
guys were funny but also had it could do
comedy and drama what I think josh is at
his best even the Avengers he can do
comedy drama at the same time really
well so what do you think about these
rumors because a lot of some people are
upset about Agent Coulson being back
because he died in the Avengers so the
rumor now is coming around that Oh agent
Coulson's actually vision what do you
think of that that that rumor
speculation I don't know her that's
rumor that's just something I heard it's
not not ain't no I mean they just say
cuz like in the very beginning the pilot
they were like we can't tell him what
happened on fears of Fiji I think
whatever he was and I don't know I mean
that could be interesting I guess even
him back I'm still not sure how I feel
about that I like him i'm glad he's a
great Clark
great actors i'm glad he's back but well
remember there's a scene in this episode
where he's trying to kill number he's
forgetting who is like oh I don't have
the muscle memory and like write me nas
like you argued Lee our little rusty
yeah I know it's interesting yeah I'm a
because he never you know had it or
without him yeah or maybe he's a robot
and we can't do it oh no um so yeah you
know it's it's not the best show in the
world but I do enjoy it there are
definitely problems I know I'm gonna
keep going with it and because of the we
did name behind it i am going to i'm not
going to give it you know some people
are only gonna give it a few episodes or
where I'm give it at least the end of
the season I'll give Lucy and I'll
probably watch all the way even if it's
not good i'll still give it to the end
of season because i know it takes a
while to be right exactly and even with
the writers with jed and his wife right
Marissa yeah so yeah just a
sister-in-law like they they were behind
Spartacus we know Spartacus didn't start
off strong you know that was more
Stephen tonight's brainchild but Jed did
help right now yeah they did a lot of
stuff on gods of the ring cuz it was
actually my favorite of the Spartacus
series they also did some episodes and
helped out a lot with dollhouse and they
actually wrote some of the best episodes
of dollhouse right so I do trust them I
trust it eventually we're gonna go
somewhere right yeah so yeah so let us
know what you think of the show if you
like it you hate it you know or you're
like us where we're like oh yeah all
right you know but you post your
comments below on the website or on our
YouTube channel that think hero pro make
sure you subscribe to that channel
Joseph us on twitter if you want talk to
Dennis ride your Dennis especially he's
at think hero i'm at griffin de and we
have saw the facebook page that's a
facebook.com / 10 care of fans
you